okay so welcome everyone uh thank you
for joining us on this saturday
afternoon uh i'm imei i'm a librarian at
library at orchard
um so
today we have uh pda and ayat
running the program of visual language
to see the real world and i just want to
announce that this week we welcome the
president's design award exhibition to
the library and we're very happy to have
them it's going to run until the 28th of
november so please do check it out make
a trip to the library visit us
pick up a copy of aya magazine
as well
and so accompanying this exhibition
together with the pda team uh trina
later you will get to see a little
she'll be sharing a bit more about the
exhibition um we welcome tanya wilson of
aya magazine to be presenting today's
sharing
um and you know it's a talk we say the
talk and it's a webinar format today but
it's not as scary and formal as
you see it seems
there is a lot of interactive segments
to today's webinar so we will be using
the chat box and the q a section quite a
lot today
so there's a difference
between the two little buttons you see
at the bottom of your screen
there will be some interactive exercises
and quizzes later
so type your responses in the chat box
but during the q a session at the end do
type the questions in that q a section
instead so another reminder is that this
session is recorded
and it will be made available to the
public on our library orchard facebook
and also on the
design singapore youtube channel so i
will be sending out and
post event email about the recording
once it's available so do keep it look
up in your inboxes
um
lastly as you can see the link at the
bottom of the screen if you like our
programs
that library entre curates that's the
link to see all the programs we have for
the month of november
and without further ado i'll just pass
the time to trina to share a little bit
more about pda and what they do
thanks emae hi everyone and thanks again
for joining us just give me a second
while i share the slides
[Music]
okay so hi again everyone i'm trina from
the design singapore council and i'm
representing the president's design
award team or pda for short
on the slide now you can see a selection
of designers and projects that have
received the award i hope you recognize
some of these designers and places and
in particular the library at orchard
which also received the pda in 2015
for using design for using the design
taking approach to design the spaces and
programs with the users in mind i'm sure
for many of us who are patrons of the
library we will agree that the library
orchard is a very welcoming space with a
lot of thoughtful design elements
so today i'm going to give a quick
introduction to the pda before i hand
the time over to tanya to start the
session
the pda is the nation's highest accolade
for designers and designs across all
disciplines it was established in 2006
and awarded in two categories designer
of the year which recognizes the
designers achievements and impact from
their body of work and design of the
year which recognizes projects for their
technical excellence as well as design
impact
so far we've awarded 43 designers of the
year and 117 designs of the year
since a revamp in 2018 the award is now
given out every two years and is jointly
organized by the design singapore
council and our colleagues from the
urban redevelopment authority
the pda also recognizes design impact in
these four areas designs power to enable
economic transformation through
transforming work experiences and
businesses through innovative design
strategies processes and even
experiences
designs that have made a difference in
raising the quality of life
projects that address culture heritage
social and community issues that advance
singapore's brand culture and community
and finally projects which push the
boundaries in crafts and technical
excellence to make groundbreaking
achievements in design
at the end of june this year we awarded
our latest crop of recipients from the
pda 2020 cycle with a small ceremony at
istana and if you're wondering why it's
2020 no that's not a mistake the cycle
was actually delayed from last year
because of covid so here are our two
designer of the year recipients that you
can see on the top row and our nine
design of the year recipients from the
various disciplines we have designs that
you can see on screen like the sparkle
thoughts large preschool at pongo which
provides a safe and inclusive space for
the young to learn and play and designs
which raise the quality of life for our
seniors like kampung moti and good life
makan
we also have projects that use design to
spotlight social issues and inside
emotions to create change like the ir
project
the pda is also more than just an award
that we give out every two years along
with it we have a traveling exhibition
that emails spoke about featuring works
of the recipients as well as local and
international outreach programs that we
run with partners like library at
orchard to inspire and educate on the
value that design can bring
these are some of the physical and
digital progress we've done and maybe we
can hope to see some of you at our
programs as well
and like email mentioned just now the
exhibition will be on display for the
whole month so you know do drop by and
check it out and check out the ir
magazine which will be at the library as
well
so every cycle we also publish a very
special lovingly designed publication
with in-depth interviews and insights
from our recipients this year we've made
it accessible to many by creating an
e-book that's free for download so you
can scan the qr code on the screen to
download a free e-copy but i'm sure all
of us who are patreon the library we
love we love our books and some of us
just prefer to read a physical copy you
know have it in our hand or maybe
display it on our shelves so for this
webinar you have a chance to receive a
limited edition hard copy if you can
email us after the session with your
biggest takeaway from the webinar and
from what tanya will be sharing
so today we have with us our recipient
from aya which uses visual
communications to break down social
issues to make us pause ponder and
perhaps change they are an excellent
example of how visual design has the
power not only to captivate but also
educate before i introduce our speaker
for today i'm going to share a quick
clip on aya
okay give me a second
[Music]
the main objective is to save the world
with creativity the idea is use visual
communication and the tricks of
advertising and try and infuse it into
education and you take something from a
highly creative industry and use its
effectiveness and its ability to affect
change that sort of stuff is really
strong and provocative and i think
that's exactly
what is needed to inspire the change
that's needed for the next generation
ten years ago with cult magazine we work
with artists and designers who are
really skilled at evoking emotions or
illustrating facts based on themes like
trust fear and
we touch slightly on social issues but
it was quite a niche audience and we
wanted to reach a much broader audience
and bring art and design and we felt it
with the right way to go was to start in
in education so our first issue was on
the dangers of the internet
and we didn't know where it would go but
then we started seeing a lot of art
teachers coming to our exhibitions and
saying they were using it as a tool to
start discussion in the classroom
and beyond singapore we're also excited
that the content has reached the uk the
us hong kong taiwan in a world where
there's so much imagery and and so much
noise how do we cut through all that so
i think by using schools and sort of
educational approach we can tell people
to analyze images in a different context
and be more careful about how they read
images
so i is designed around this
visual trigger to trigger a conversation
or a discussion in a classroom it also
encourages them to look a bit deeper and
harder into the details of an image that
only reveal themselves on the second
viewing so i think it's both of those
things it's revealing hidden messages
but it's also training a sort of
visual
literacy
we as parents i feel that children need
to know about things like internet
safety and healthy eating and
sustainability and mental wellness and
financial literacy we feel those topics
are really important and combining the
powerful visuals with those really
highly relevant but sometimes sensitive
and complex topics serves as the
inspiration behind ayah
[Music]
okay i hope you guys enjoyed that
so before i go on to introduce tania
just give me a second and pull out the
slides again
okay i'm very happy to introduce tanya
who's the co-founder and education lead
of aya and together with our other
co-founder and creative director steve
lawler we have worked with an impressive
list of clients from around the world as
well as a network of designers and
artists both in the commercial and
cultural sectors tanya has a background
in public relations events and
communications and she is key in the
strategic strategic growth of ayah and
its future i'll now hand the time over
to tanya welcome tania
thank you trina hello everyone
um
i'm saying hello to you all from the
middle of the south china sea this is
the first time i i run a webinar in this
uh in these kind of conditions i'm
actually on a cruise
and um
i'm
that's why it's i look very bright it's
her son's right behind me
and i'm sat next to the it person
because the connection isn't great here
so i hope it doesn't cut out but um i'm
delighted um that you've all joined on
your saturday at lunchtime and um
although i can't see you all i'm
hoping this is going to be a really fun
and interactive session so i'm gonna
start sharing screen
okay i just need to enable screen
sharing
okay
so the title as you know is a visual
language to see the real world
um so
sorry hold on i'm just adjusting okay
so this session is designed to
demonstrate how images can be used to
develop curiosity visual literacy
creative confidence and critical
thinking skills the important thing to
realize in this session is there are no
right or wrong answers
and hopefully you're going to have a lot
of fun um what i've learned through the
time that i've been through the 20 years
that i've been working in visual
communications is that images can be a
very powerful way to develop these key
skills and hopefully you're going to get
a taste of that
i'm going to take you through my journey
to um to visual communications
um how we and why we decided to build
this brand for kids and kids and then
we'll do some creative thinking and
critical thinking exercises followed by
a q a
and i've got my colleague becca here as
well um in case i in case there's a
wi-fi problem and i log off and then
i'll log back on again and she'll take
over from me
and
yeah without further ado let's let's
begin we're going to begin by by just
asking you some questions about um
creativity
um
these are some common uh beliefs
and i am i love to see what all of you
think so if you can uh becca's gonna put
the the code the url in the chat box
if you can have a go at telling me what
your opinion on each of these statements
these widely believed statements is
okay i can see you're all starting to
respond
uh becca would you mind sharing the
screen
actually i can probably oh becca's gonna
do it thanks becca
so
okay well
okay so it's it's oh great so
it sounds like we've got a really an
audience of designers and and uh people
who understand visual literacy which is
fantastic
um and who believe visual literacy is
important even better i mean i've not
done one of these webinars with this
audience before but i i imagine there's
a lot of designers and people who work
in visual comms here so lovely to meet
you all
um
okay but there is a belief that that
creativity is being good at um at
drawing and arts and crafts
um
it's it's actually
a lot more than that and in this session
we'll be really talking about creative
thinking um not in the terms of arts and
crafts
creative thinking can be taught
so it looks like
like you believe that
um of those of you who have voted
i think 12 of you
um
and
yes definitely it can
some people are creative and some aren't
seems like about half of you believe
that
and creativity is relevant to certain
jobs only yeah but that is a common
belief
um but actually i would say it's
relevant to to a lot of jobs and more
and more as we're going to be discussing
later and a lot of you believe it's
difficult to measure um yes that is
definitely a common a common belief so
let's let's uh continue the session now
so you saw the video earlier and you've
got an idea of what we do but we we want
to create a world where innovative
mindsets are nurtured from young we want
to inspire then the
new generation to build more equal and
environmentally conscious society
because of our background in in visual
comms
we want to use the tricks of advertising
and apply it into education
so using creativity to deliver
educational content it can work on two
levels
one we can make difficult or sensitive
subject matter approachable and
interesting and you saw earlier in the
video i was talking about topics like
internet safety sustainability healthy
eating all topics that we feel that
children should be learning about in
school and they are
more and more
but we want to support the the
curriculum with with this kind of
content and two by constantly exposing
children to creativity and training
their creative muscles they will become
creative because studies show that by
the age of 11 there's a dip in
children's self-belief in their creative
abilities and that by the time they
leave school they no longer see
themselves as being creative
i just want to talk to you a bit about
my journey in um in visual
communications i moved to singapore in
2005 to start a global platform for
tiger beer called tiger translate and
that's when i met my my co-founder steve
lawler and this platform we worked on
for about seven years and we found in
emerging creatives from all across asia
and partnered them up with with
designers and
illustrators from western countries to
collaborate and to create um a lot of
content and experiences so and it was we
we ended up growing up quite a large
network because we were on covering
illustrators in all these different
countries this is manila
he was from hong kong and you can see
how elements of the brand are built into
these beautiful illustrations these
digital illustrations that were then
applied across bottles and merchandise
and various other items
at the same time we started
doing this free visual magazine called
cult that we produced about i think 14
issues and what what was
amazing about this is we actually gave
every issue away for free and again we
started building this network
and it meant that we never had to pitch
for work we always got clients coming to
us because they wanted to use this kind
of visual language
for for themselves and what kind of
clients were they well actually it was
it was really interesting brands like
nike facebook netflix
um you will know that
that um
we can process visuals sixty thousand
times faster than text those of you who
who
are quite visually illiterate
and using images to convey information
improves a person's ability to recall
facts
uh by an average of 23
and when texts and graphics are combined
retention increases to 42 percent
[Music]
so you'll probably never forget that
fact now
but the average 7-eleven
big gulp is 50 bigger than the volume of
the human stomach
so
we started doing these little fun facts
and animating these illustrations
um and these are some of the the clients
that we worked with yeah so when we work
with clients like nike they wanted us to
find illustrators from all over asia
places like myanmar laos cambodia
mongolia
so and we were able to find talent in
all those countries
some of the works that we did
and for coca-cola
and facebook facebook wanted us to
illustrate some of their um their facts
so that they could make their
presentations to clients more visual
and interesting rather than just copy
based
general electric a brand that is
not seen as a very young brand
um gave us all these facts and stats
about their powerful machines and we
visualized them and this created content
for social media for them to engage with
a more with a younger audience
uh
this is a three-way uh collaboration
that we organized in bangkok for
stranger things too so we got three
street artists and uh and a sculptor to
make this uh
this um installation in an abandoned
nightclub
some other uh
outdoor installations that we've
commissioned
jiff fest is a bi-annual festival of
creativity that we hold
and we for this we do a call out for
for artisan designers to create an
animated gif to a special theme
and this has been growing over the years
we started off with
a few hundred submissions and and then
in the previous one a couple of years
ago we had over 500.
i'll talk a bit about that later but all
these um
all these are really opportunities to
create animated gifs and and as you'll
see from from this next one which is one
of my favorites you can communicate a
hell of a lot of information in a in a
gif and and this is why this guy who
from spain
um had never
in the breakfast buffet sorry i'll play
it again this is one of my favorite and
the breakfast buffet his hotel was
wondering what the orange and the green
jam was and he asked the waiter and
that's how he learned about kaya
and so he built this gif to show kind of
celebrate singapore and and how the
process of making kaya
and naturally this guy is huge um
on nft platforms and and selling his
gifs and he's had collectors from
singapore write to him and ask him to
make more of these
so he starts off doing this um by hand
drawing it and then bringing it into
procreate and then animating it
so going into i are now that was just to
show you a bit about how we've built
this this network of about 1 500 visual
communicators
when we became parents and our kids are
in local school we started seeing the
opportunity to
use our network to to talk to kids about
difficult topics
so we combined social issues with
creativity and we call it creativity
with a conscious and this really started
us off as a passion project there was
absolutely no
um commercial idea behind it we just
wanted to do something that we would be
proud of as parents and kind of uh
something that we we really love doing
every single day um and we and it
started i kind of grew and grew like
that and then and then you know thanks
thanks for design singapore we won the
award which has helped us raise the
profile
why why do we do it as most of you know
i think you will know about the future
of work
at the world economic forum and the key
skills for the future of work because
machines are replacing humans
what can
can humans do that machines can't
critical thinking creative thinking and
complex problem solving and we believe
that images can be used to develop those
skills well we don't it's not us who
believe there's been academic papers
written about it as well
so some of the partnerships that we've
had
um
foreign
now i realize you're not hearing the
sound on these animations so sorry about
that but um you can see them all on
youtube we've got over 50 of them and we
played them in between shows on
nickelodeon as a little public service
announcements
some of the things we've done is our
printed magazine a magazine is really
really hard to especially a visual
magazine with zero adverts is really
hard to
to scale and to maintain but
um at the end of the day we love the
printed format of the magazine and we
really want to continue it uh we
regularly get parents who say to us that
they're looking for magazines to
subscribe to for their children
so um yeah as long as possible we want
to keep the magazine exhibitions are a
key way that we reach out to people
workshops the school kits which is
growing more and more
um our youtube animations that really we
make for nickelodeon are merchandise
which we're starting to sell in quite a
few places now in singapore um our
interactive learning experiences we
wanted to push the boundaries of
publishing so we created these
interactive experiences that are on in
the app store
so going back to visual literacy i think
most of you know about visual literacy
but
looking at an image is similar to
skimming a text while seeing an image as
comparable to reading it
and it is important to be visually
literate to understand pictures and how
they affect us as as it is to be word
literate
because of the digital world that we
live in a new visual language has
emerged yet we're not taught how to read
images
years are spent teaching students
grammar and paragraph construction so
that they become strong written
communicators but rarely is the same
attention spent on the elements of
visual communication
as i'm sure all of you will know
if you see a heavily uh report that's
really heavy in text
you are maybe less likely to engage in
it than if it's really beautifully
illustrated and makes for a really nice
reading experience
and even better if the images
complement the text or say something
that the text can't say
so we use the images as visual triggers
um you observe you discuss and then it
will enable these learning outcomes
okay i'm going to answer some of the
story i saw one of the questions yeah
the magazines are really hard to find
because we just don't print that in any
um and they are very difficult to find
you can get some online um or bashir we
try we really love bashir
so here are some of the the learning
outcomes
okay we're going to start having a bit
of fun now
so i want you this is some of the
exercises that we do with teachers that
we do with us with the kids um any age
so caption contest i don't know if you
remember but when i was young there were
it was quite a frequent thing in the
newspapers in england
um can you come up with a fun title for
this artwork so if you could um share in
the in the chat some ideas don't be shy
um this is some of the things that we do
in our creative thinking workshops and
the idea is that the more original the
more unusual
your response the that yeah exactly
broccoli power
um and what's interesting is when you
see other people's
responses
um
and and it can be really really
really fun okay i can see this only
jennifer's commented for now that's fine
you might take time to to warm up
uh yes very nice brocco man
um
so let's have a look at some
some other people's so we have this in
our app and the idea is when you start
seeing other people's comments you can
you can like them and build on them and
see how how people will interpret things
in different ways
so just going a bit more into into
visual literacy and later i'm going to
share some books that i love about this
topic
um if you have a careful look at this
image i think all of you are adults and
you'll probably
probably be able to understand this
image already but if you observe all the
small details and start to interpret it
and then if i tell you that the image is
called the artwork is called blocking
unwanted calls
then you'll realize obviously the window
is actually an iphone
and what we're interested in is in that
aha moment when you look at an image you
deconstruct it and you understand it
and that is the act of visual literacy
because the pleasure of decoding um what
happens is the viewer makes the
necessary act of completion
and the urge to understand and to
complete something is intrinsic to human
nature
decoding the image leads to admiration
for the cleverness of the visual and
also satisfaction with one's own
cleverness for interpreting it
and that leads to intellectual
gratification
and it's a
real human need to to understand an
image
so let's have a look at this one do you
notice anything unusual about it and
what do you think is the social
commentary why don't you uh chat put in
some some some of your thoughts in the
chat what do you think this image is
about
so you'll see this is quite normal at
the start of these workshops that we run
people are a bit shy to share but by the
end of it
they're all sharing their ideas
sweet bomb yes
okay perfect so you you get it straight
away you can see that actually the body
of the cupcake is a snake and that
there's these eyeballs and the cherry on
top is actually a bomb
yeah and and what is the social commit
tree yes so i can see some very nice
very nice comments coming in now and the
social commentary is really about the
dangers of sugars and hidden sugars
[Music]
so making connections is is a key part
of a designer and a creative person is
their ability to connect to things that
are just don't even seem related
and we can see this done visually
um
here you have the iphone and the and the
and the hands and then i can ask you to
look at these two components and imagine
what you think is going to happen
i'm gonna ask you to listen
hold on
oh
so what do you think is going to happen
from from that so if we were
in a classroom environment then i would
the teacher would ask the students and
get them to watch the animation
so this is this is interesting because
um
when i've done this workshop previously
and asked people what this was about
everyone kind of shared about the idea
of social media
and the idea of
drowning in technology
so
um a lot of people really relate to that
animation
um and then
once you've i've got your attention by
sharing this animation i can
then share information with you
that
people in singapore spend more time on
the internet than any other country in
the world apart from india
so it starts the images and the
animations start are a way of are an
opener to start discussing these topics
that may otherwise be quite heavy
and that you don't want to be
approaching by telling young people get
off the internet it's dangerous for you
because that's not going to work they're
not going to react to that
so let's look at the same this is
actually the same illustrator her name
is yay chloe and we're a big fan of her
work
because we actually did an uh we
actually did her first solo show in
singapore a few years ago
um and now she's huge on nft platforms
as well
um
so she has these she creates these you
can follow her on instagram at yay chloe
she creates these these images that are
really striking and full of meaning
[Music]
so um
you know that idea of puzzles
um and observation exercises i think
it's something that we do when we're
really young
and then we somehow just stop doing them
or don't do them so often but what we
don't realize is they actually nurture
observation which is an absolutely
fundamental skill that is at the at the
basis of creative thinking creative
people are highly observant people so
are designers who solve problems because
they will observe be able to observe
things so these kind of puzzles help
nurture and build those muscles
and of course the animation is also
about the topic of healthy eating and
about and about excess excess sugar
because kids of course start drinking
soda at a very young age
there's even sodas available in some
schools
so this is a way to start a discussion
about soft drinks and have an active
discussion on the topic and again
without starting off by saying to kids
don't drink soft drinks they're bad for
you which they won't react so well to
maybe not be as effective as having the
discussion in this way
so i talked about observation just now
and i'm just going to show some some
other types of illustration
that nurture observation so i'm sure all
of you remember or maybe are still huge
fans of where's wally
or where's world though
so we love these kind of really highly
detailed illustrations and we commission
them around these hot topics
so this one is about smart devices so
what i'm going to do now is give you a
few minutes to look at the picture and
find the 18 smart devices it's actually
um not that easy so please feel feel
free to share in the in the chat some of
the devices that you spot
yeah drone
laptops definitely quite a lot
laptops and tablets including the guy
who's who's or the lady who's on her on
the toilet on her tablet vr yes very
good for the washing machine excellent
that that's a
that's a smart washing machine smart tv
yep the vr goggles
um but the car how about the car did
anyone notice that
someone put robot uh
interesting i don't know where the robot
is
um satellite smart toilet it could be a
smart toilet um i don't think it was
intended i think you did you no one's
yet said the um
this one where is he the runner he's got
that the the tracking the running
tracking device
she's looking for love on the internet
spaceships yep
robot arm yes exactly very good and
what's that it's a worm um that he's
holding and this is a a reference to um
worms that you can find on the internet
yeah online dating and then there's a
hole in the road as you can see and
that's a reference to the idea of of
going down a hole down a wormhole down
the internet
alien baby okay well fantastic i mean i
can see you can see how this uh
generates discussion and i mean sadly i
can't see you all
but you can imagine that in a classroom
this could be really really fun actually
for any age
um and then you can start asking people
and also the gaming the gaming device
yeah exactly you can uh yes exactly the
danger of vr falling down
um you could start asking people oh oh
or kids you know have you tried vr and
you will start getting an idea of how
how
smart device literate the kids are
probably in many cases more so than the
teachers
so here we go
they're all circled here i think you
guys you guys found them more
so what what is absolutely unbelievable
is that i don't know if you notice that
well that there are more gadgets than
humans and in fact by 2023 there are
going to be three types more network
devices on earth than humans
um and then what else do you remember
seeing well that's when we can go into
into all the small details like i was
talking about the worm and the wormhole
and and and the like the vr man who's
about to fall off the roof and then we
can have all those kind of discussions
together
i'm not going to give you a break um
well if because
i think we're doing good for time and i
want to give you a chance to ask
questions
but this is another
um one of our star illustrations she's
actually esther go from singapore um the
previous guy was called matt stokes we
always
credit our illustrators
and for many it's a new way of
discovering is of discovering talent and
you'll see when your instagram feed
becomes rich with all these creators it
kind of adds a whole new dimension to to
your life
um so this is called emoji land
and every single little icon here is
actually an emoji
and you can have a whole
learning experience about nonverbal
communication and about actually how
emojis are not universal
one emoji
in one culture may mean something
completely different in another one
so that's really really interesting
um
you know and i find when i'm learning
new things then then definitely the kids
will be learning new stuff as well
uh and i don't know if you can see the
ir one eye tiger hiding here if anyone
can please write it in the
in the chat
um we actually took this and we put it
into a vr device
we worked with a with a guy who who used
unreal i think it was
and it was it was really really fun for
the kids for many of them it was their
first time trying out vr
no he's not in the middle actually
maybe you can write um which icon he's
next to the one the aya tiger and what
happened in the vr is that when they
found the tiger and zoomed in on it it
unlocked another scene for them
anyone seen him yes quite okay
i will spotted him he's next to the
giant syringe at the top top left
so we're gonna do another one this is
this is actually the my zoom background
this is angie
um angie neo who's from singapore and
she's uh does these she's pretty amazing
she does
a huge amount of research
um
so i'm gonna ask you to find the 18
hidden penguins
if you we were doing a zoom workshop um
you could we could do not on webinar
formats but in another format um you can
actually work um
use the annotation tool on zoom to
circle all the penguins
so that's really fun of course you can
do it manually
so what happened is is that steve asked
angie to to do an igloo that was on fire
and a scene of chaos in the arctic to
talk about global warming
and she did a huge amount of research
and what she's done is kind of embedded
her research into this rich illustration
so in the top right you will see that
the melting ice cap and actually those
those spiky things are viruses that are
being exposed that have been frozen in
the ice for thousands of years and that
are actually very dangerous to humans
then you'll see the
the um
mosquito up there holding viruses and
bacterias because the rising
temperatures are causing them to breed
um you'll see the plastic bottle the
nice nice mountain
you know plastic bottles have been found
on everest and in the arctic
um
you'll of course find find all the
penguins you'll see that the the the
bike um the yellow bike because bike
sharing schemes can be very wasteful if
they're not implemented properly
you will see of course the reference to
andy warhol with the campbell tomato
soup which is one of her favorite
favorite artists
so this is an image that you can really
have quite a rich discussion about and
learn about global warming rising
temperatures rising sea levels even some
of the causes
uh with the plastic and the and the
waste
so they were all the penguins
and and i've sort of circle i've we i
talked about that earlier
okay divergent thinking the idea of
divergent thinking these all these parts
are all pillars to creative thinking and
divergent thinking is the idea of coming
up with many many
um ideas to a problem
so this is um an example of how we would
do this so what do you think this this
image is communicating
so i think you you or you all can you
know you all can guess that the family
is sat at dinner just looking at their
devices not talking this is a scene that
really resonates with a lot of people
so how what activity would we do we'd
ask the students to imagine a friend has
been spending too long online and their
work is suffering and as a result
what suggestions would you give them on
how to use their device less list five
out of the box ideas
and the great thing about this and
please feel free to start sharing
um your ideas the great thing about this
is that when you use digital tools like
padlet or even this zoom session you
start seeing other people's ideas and
you realize wow there are so many
different ideas the more you push
yourself the more you'll have
unconventional ideas and and we want to
celebrate those
yeah so switch off wi-fi yes and and
then you if you keep pushing you'll get
more and more
i've done this previously
yeah take up sports yeah exactly
people were saying put put the tie the
mobile phone in the in the hide the
mobile phone card game yeah so
you can see
pull out the plants yes
great and then some people are starting
to talk about
features or apps
nice
so divergent thinking is is so notice
how your first few thoughts are usually
the most obvious
push yourself to find three to five
alternative thoughts that also fit the
situation
so this is another
similar activity and the reason i'm
doing double of all the activities is
that you see the more that you do the
more your creative muscles will build
and the better you will get
so imagine a friend has been the target
of online bullying what advice would you
give them on how to handle it
so that's another way that we encourage
divergent thinking we're not going to do
this one now because um i want to do the
the quiz which is coming up coming up
soon
um
but the idea is to applaud crazy crazy
answers and what we find in the
classroom
oh yes this is very cute so five
push-ups each time you look at your
phone
so what what you find in a classroom
when you're doing this kind of thing is
that the kids who are really really good
usually in the classroom are not
necessarily the best ones at this
sometimes it's actually the students who
are the the weaker students who are
really good at these activities why
because they're not afraid of saying
stupid things
so that that's very kind of an
interesting insight and what i find is
great is is to let those kids shine
um
and and let them feel confident
critical thinking
um
so you know this is this is something
that we address in our fake news issue
we found unbelievable research that
students um believe
that what they see online
is true
um it was a stanford study that showed
that and it was kids up to about 13 14
they they believe everything they see
online
so what we did is we created this fake
news quiz we actually researched real
fake news stories
um
and and uh we we created these little
animated graphics and then we put it in
a cahoot quiz kahu is really popular
because it allows you to see how
how everyone else is doing so you can
have a go at that now becca's going to
put that paste the
the link there
um
and there's about
10 questions we've got three quizzes but
you can please have a go it's quite fun
and and you probably see as you do it
that it's impossible to know whether
whether a headline is true or false
in this day and age false stuff can seem
real and real stuff can seem false so we
had a lot of fun doing this quiz because
when we were invent trying to invent
fake headlines
we were finding that they were actually
in a way real
or becoming real so it was kind of a
funny activity
so i'm going to give you a few minutes
to to have a go at that
is
okay i hope you enjoyed that so
the cahoot quiz is really a another way
to start a discussion about fake news
and as a as a prompt
um
to
to make
young people realize that
sometimes it's just you just can't read
something and no so after that you would
then go into a discussion of how do you
verify the validity of a story and then
you can have more of a serious
discussion
but the quiz is a great way to introduce
this topic which is actually very very
complex
but very very important
so any of you who've got kids please
please feel free to do that with them
kids love kahu and if there's any
teachers then please feel free to have a
go with them the great thing is that
they can uh
the great thing about kahu is they've
got this live uh sort of a rating so
they see who's who's top in the class at
the quiz and so they love that
competitive element
okay sorry hold on
okay
so creative confidence
um you know creative confidence is
something that um
that can grow that will grow with time i
think maybe kids start off creatively
confident but i don't know who's watched
ken robinson's ted talk that the famous
ted talks about schools killing
creativity they may come out not feeling
so confident anymore and that is a real
problem because
maybe at the beginning some people said
oh creativity is not relevant in all
businesses but actually i would argue
that it is it's simply that people that
there's a deep-held belief within the
company that it's not relevant
probably because those those leaders do
not feel creatively confident themselves
however this self-assurance lies at the
heart of innovation
so it's so important to nurture this
creative creativity as a value within
your organization
so this is another activity that we do
in the fake news and this is really very
fun so please have a go now you've got
nine there are nine images and you've
got to think of a short story or
headline that combines any three in an
original way and remember there are no
right or wrong answers and i'm gonna
give you a few minutes to have a go
alright
okay
very nice jennifer
rabbit use this uh cheese grater to
break out of prison brilliant
okay i think maybe jennifer must work in
in a creative uh job i don't know i'm
just oh well okay so you're all
fantastic i think you all work in
creative industries
um and maybe you don't anyway i'm
curious myself to know that because
you're all very good at this
okay very good tb rabbit receives prison
sentence for cooking the world's worst
pizza i mean that is brilliant
must remember that one becca we can put
it in our
in the school kit as an example of a
really funny one
pizza hut starters in jail
okay you guys are very good this is uh
top top group i've had so far i must say
yeah all very natural at this i i hope i
i wonder um how creatively confident you
all are i suspect probably quite very
confident
lifeguard spotted taxi floating on ocean
yeah brilliant
these are brilliant
um these are even better than the ones
that that we came up with i think
these are these are our ones
so amazing how you can see the variety
of combinations that you can come up
with you know imagine this in a
classroom of 40
um and imagine letting the kids use a
tool like padlet where they can like
each other's
that's called rewarding unusual thinking
yeah
very good very funny so this is kind of
like making me smile um
i think having fun we could and
creativity really go hand in hand
okay i think it's not the same
jennifer's done and another one which is
which is amazing you know just goes to
show one person can also push themselves
to to make more and more
so inc so encourage students to do this
multiple times
to stretch creative muscles and
uses it uses the making connections
method to generate new idea and build
creative confidence
and what are you going to see when you
start doing this is that
these these kids these young people
adults will start being able to combine
unusual things and unusual ideas to
create something new
and that is where
innovation comes from i'm sure when you
read all the stories about amazing
innovators
and where they got their ideas from
you'll actually find it some from making
connections between things that do not
necessarily naturally go together and i
always find that fascinating about steve
jobs and the and the mac and when he
started out he remembered his
calligraphy class that he'd taken at
college just happens to be that he just
took this extra class and he remembered
the
the importance of
of this of design and and that is
something he incorporated early on into
the mac which straight away
distinguished it from the other pcs on
the market at the time so he made that
connection
at the time
so that's obviously a an example of uh
what they call big c creativity but it's
just to show this this is really
important
so content creation um creative people
people are natural creators
but now with social media you don't you
don't have to have to be some a trained
designer to be able to create not even
with social media now with smart devices
so this is an exercise that we did for
our fake news we created these gif
stickers
and we asked people to create fake news
stories
so you might not necessarily want to
have a go at this now but you could have
a go at this
later um if you go on to jiffy you'll
see our
some of our fake news
stories i will show you some now as well
much
so by using tools such as social media
you can really start to to raise
awareness of these topics in a in a fun
way
so these are all gift stickers
so i'm coming to the end of the webinar
i mean coming to the question and answer
session but i just wanted to to let you
know what we're currently working on um
we want to talk about anxiety we want to
do an anxiety themed issue of ayah so
that's that's what we've been
researching and
what's amazing is that
around it's actually one in five now
of the world's children and adolescents
have a mental disorder and generalized
anxiety typically begins in adolescence
we want to make it um
okay to talk about mental health and
fight the stigma around the topic
so we're going to demystify and
visualize anxiety so we've already
reached out to our network and and
really researched this topic at length
we want to normalize anxiety and um
make it uh into something that you can
have a conversation about in the
classroom and empower people to
recognize their own symptoms
and have authentic conversations
so social media
and how you how you look how you feel
you look on social media
covered these are some of the topics
we're going to cover fear of making or
taking phone calls fear of exams fear of
school
i know my kids for example are actually
petrified of coved
of testing positive
to them it's like uh the scariest thing
ever
so you know and that they're seven years
old so they already have anxiety around
you know at this age
so i think at this time
this is um
really really important to do this
so we're going to combine our um earlier
on i mentioned some of the events and
exhibitions that we hold and we're going
to combine that we want to to make this
really high profile you unfortunately
you can't print a magazine that most
people can't get hold of you have to do
something much more high profile and
that's why we're going to do an
exhibition a free exhibition art science
museum in march next year um it's going
to be called gfs3 and we're going to be
showing all these gifs about anxiety but
it's going to be fun
so
um and i think that's that's a a unique
sort of position that we're in to curate
something like that to take a topic that
is actually obviously quite heavy to
distill it and to create an experience
about it that you actually will enjoy
but that will spark discussion and uh
maybe recognition in people
so we want to build installations and
and have all these amazing gifs that of
course are are rich for
nfts as well
so here's an example of a sketch that
we've just received from jim the
illustrator one of our creators
and it's about anxiety and i'm gonna let
you look at it because the more you look
the more you'll uncover and actually
hopefully you'll even like laugh and
enjoy looking at this
so i just give you a few minutes a
minute to have a look
so when we when this came in and the
team and i were going through it
everyone has a different
a different part of it that they love
that makes them smile i personally love
the comic strip on the right
i like the little man who's getting
squashed by the shoe
um and you know this isn't even colored
and it's not even animated so you can
see as it gets elevated and elevated
the power of something like this and the
power of a creator who's able to capture
so much in in such a rich illustration
we're coming to the end now i'd love to
get some of your um so i hope you've had
fun for me this is a key quote about
creativity's intelligence having fun
um it would be really nice to get your
reflection some of the
um some of your thoughts about about in
three words how you felt feel after this
session
um maybe you experience the idea of a
state of flow i always find that really
interesting but a status flow is how you
feel when you're being truly creative
and it's a state of feeling really happy
at ease and really relax
maybe some of your assumptions have
changed
for me learning about creativity and
creative thinking i've realized it can
be taught it can be nurtured you can
build creative confidence and it should
be from young
so yes please go ahead and i'll have a
look at some of your
hmm
thank you becca
great i mean i love your your words i i
feel the same as well energize inspired
happy yeah fun eye-opening great i mean
educational um
you know i i would my my sort of goal um
in life is to is to get these exercises
in as many classrooms as possible and i
think by using these topics that
teachers and parents want kids to know
about is a way of doing that
um
curious yeah curiosity is is
that this one is so important because
um
you know the ken robinson ted talk i
talked about earlier
um
so schools kill creativity well actually
recently they're now starting to talk
about
um schools killing curiosity
so um if we need to keep kids curious we
need to be curious about the world
jumpy okay i'm not sure what um
well yeah what that's referring to but
but interesting
um i i would love to have some of your
questions later
okay great well i'm i'm glad you uh you
all feel that way i think that's really
nice really nice feedback
i'm just going to finish off
by just
going back to
cher
i love reading
i just recently
finished a masters and that reignited my
love of reading
nonfiction i'm a huge fan of nlb
um thus i'm here on my on my cruise in
the middle of the day doing this
um
i i love that the fact that you can you
can borrow all the books through the
through the app um online and download
them in minutes
it's amazing and actually nearly all the
books that i want are always available
so yes thank you nlb these are some of
my favorite favorite books about
creativity
um
i loved um
some of them are very new maybe nlb
don't have them yet but the art of
creative thinking they definitely have
how to have great ideas they definitely
have i love this a smile in the mind
all of you here who are into graphic
design or visual communications this is
really um even the title is so nice you
know it's the idea of looking at an
image and
and and feeling happy or
or you know it's about humor it's a
really beautiful book visual
intelligence is was a bit aha for me
because i really learned about visual
literacy and i love this book about
creating innovators
um
it's really about raising kids to be
creative and it's about the small things
that matter so much in your journey to
creativity
like having mentors like having people
that believe in you
um i'm really i love interviewing
creative people
about their their journey and i find
that there are some common threads
another thing is reading is a common
thread and often they read completely
out of their area of expertise
some of them even go to obscure parts of
the library and find books on topics
that are completely not what they're
into
and we'll read about them science
fiction
um i mean you will know how how
science fiction predicts the future
often so
so those are some some great books and
here are some
uh our
social media
so so please follow um yeah so
playful graphics oh okay nice thank you
yes please feel free to share i mean
there's not much time left thank you so
much i'm i will enjoy my cruise
if you have any questions please go
ahead
um
yeah i know i i mean i'm it's it's first
time i do a webinar i think it's a shame
i can't see you all but um
it's it's i've enjoyed your your
comments
so thank you
okay so uh i think
uh if anyone has any questions you can
just input into the q a section as well
um we have one question from haril so
far he says thank you for this truly fun
and interactive webinar
as someone who better understands and
digests information in a visual way i
really wish there was something of a
similar nature back when i was in school
just wondering will there be reprints of
your physical magazine issues that are
currently out of stock um
yeah i i we would like but we've been
asked um
that question a few times and we would
love to do reprints um
it's it's really our biggest challenge
usually is just um
it's just how to pay for things
um
so but but yes we would love to you know
i think this this work is timeless and
um it should be reprinted so if i can
gather enough
teachers
or people to
pay for a reprint definitely and thank
you for saying that you wish there was
something similar when you were back at
school i i wish the same as well
okay do we have any other questions for
the q and a section
uh the ir magazine is available at
library at orchards so you can just hit
down and try to borrow a physical copy
but they are really popular um so they
do get borrowed out quite fast but you
can always check on the nlb app if they
are available before heading down as
well
okay we've got another question what are
some of the biggest challenges
throughout the whole creative journey
and how do you overcome it
good question
yeah that is a good question um
uh
hmm
gosh
what
there's there's been um a lot of
challenges i think for me personally and
maybe other people on the team will will
say something different
um
it's it's hard to to sustain something
like this
um because it's really not commercial
and we don't have a fixed business model
um so then you you start going on the
tracks of are you are you a non-profit
which we actually are but being a
non-profit is a bit doesn't mean much
you really need to be a charity to
benefit in that sense
uh which we're not
so not having a business model is is
difficult because it means it's really
hard to sustain it's hard to do reprints
it's it's hard to pay to do things so
that is our biggest challenge to be
honest how do you overcome it well
it's a constant challenge but we
overcome it by i think uh
by getting recognition and thanks by
doing sessions like this and and seeing
that people are truly inspired and truly
enjoy it by the teachers that we talked
to by the awards that we were in so that
those things just keep us doing it
because we see that there's value in
that it makes a difference
what other topics yeah this that's a
great question there's the topics we
really want to do are
money which is financial literacy i mean
the amount of even adults who are not
financially literate is is unbelievable
and so um i'm trying to get a bank to
sponsor that but you know sometimes i
think even banks don't necessarily want
people to be truly financially literate
so then the question is you know who's
going to pay for that
um
yeah so financial literacy um
we want to do uh even like jokes we've
just got like humor like the human brain
and even we want to start tackling those
typical subjects at school like science
maths
and doing it in a completely new way
okay
another question from tin is there any
commercial opportunities that i have
rejected and why
um
[Music]
we
i don't know about uh there there are
opportunities that we've that we've
rejected simply because we we don't have
the the full capacity to do them or that
we didn't feel they were
um
they
weren't really
uh driving our values maybe
um
but we've been very we're quite
fortunate in that we've the partners we
work with now really value what we do
um
so
so yeah i hope that answers that
question
yes crowdfunding i know it is quite a
good suggestion we have been told that a
few times so thank you for that
bye real
wait does anyone have any more questions
uh about maybe the pda exhibition as
well we have some people from the team
that can answer any of your questions
uh some people have been asking about
the ebooks uh for the ayah magazine and
becca's uh just posted a link to see
more editions of that on the ayah page
so definitely check that out
uh i think from the chat we've got from
cynthia it's the march exhibition date
fixed
people are very excited about the
exhibition at the art science museum
that sounds amazing
yes actually it's not even formally
announced yet so you guys are
wow
yeah there isn't there is it is during a
wee long holiday in march i forgot
exactly maybe the 12th the 15th around
there it's on for two weeks
but but we're still trying to find a
sponsor to pay for it to be honest
so but but hopefully hopefully it will
happen
okay maybe you can just keep the
questions coming uh i would just share
my screen
uh to get some feedback for today's
session so let me just share that
okay
okay hope everyone can see the qr code
and the link so if you enjoyed today's
session please let us know and if you
want to see any
similar programs your feedback helps us
uh kind of plan what programs to go with
uh
for the next year we are a design
library so we're really happy to be the
only
uh
design focused public library under nlp
uh and yeah we're really happy to have
partners like tanya and such amazing
project being shared i know we've got a
comment just now that you know this is a
really interactive session and yeah i
think this is the most interactive
webinar i've been in as well and thank
you to tanya and the team for just
adapting so well uh to the online
formats and everything i think everyone
really enjoyed today's session
yeah thank you all and we love the nlb
like i've said and we love to do pop-up
exhibitions in the library
so um i'm just putting it out there for
you um to begin
bring this yeah to a wide audience so
you know you know it's there if the
offer is there um
okay we've got another question so are
there differences in visual comms for
children as opposed to seniors
no i mean
yeah yeah
by doing this by running sessions like
this
you could do this exact same session
with a load of kids with a load of
teenagers and and with with seniors
you would it would be so um it's so
interesting
to see people's um how people see things
and how people perceive and when you
start really going into visual literacy
and the depth of it you realize that the
way you perceive something is to do with
your your your perspective is to do with
your biases your pre your assumptions
and your previous experience and no two
people will necessarily look at an image
in the same way
and images are a way to for people to
actually have a discussion and realize
their own biases so i think you can
really use that for seniors you would
make it perhaps a bit more sophisticated
maybe the images would be more
sophisticated than for children
but the idea and the approach would be
the same
great
okay so while we've got lots of thank
yous in the chat thank you everyone for
making it for today
we still got the room to we still got
this webinar on for a while so we can
hang around for a bit
but yeah feel free to type in the chat
thank you hannah thank you i real
thank you everybody oh um and just a
reminder that uh
there is you can win a
physical publication of the pda
uh
pda publication uh you just gotta email
a pda maybe you can get someone from the
team to
put that in the chat again
so i have a copy myself and it's great
so definitely i recommend
popping them an email if you have time
okay great becca just
put the email in the chat again
okay
tanya how are you going to spend the
rest of the day
on your cruise
wow i'm not sure really there's a lot a
lot of places to eat
yeah a lot of food and um it's really
hot i've been but i've been endorsed
this whole time so i'm not sure but when
i was outside earlier it was really
really hot like you can imagine we're
just in the middle of the sea that's
yeah
it's the
first time i've done a a cruise like i
don't think uh i would be doing cruises
if it wasn't for covid but
that was an assumption of mine that
cruises are a bit like
i don't know i just had assumptions but
actually now i'm like oh they're
actually quite fun
like floating resorts
i feel like i'm an advert for the for
the royal caribbean
wow but thanks was thanks so much for
spending time with us this afternoon
it was fun i mean it's it's nice to have
such positive feedback and also a quite
engaged audience that are
clearly quite creative themselves
so it's a pleasure thanks for organizing
no problem
okay i'm just gonna stop sharing
let's see
okay we don't have any more questions i
think i'll just close this webinar will
be five minutes early
okay
yeah
thanks becca thanks patreon thanks trina
thank you everyone
enjoy your saturday the rest of your
weekend
thanks everyone
okay see you guys bye